bonsoir mais avant tout cela un nouveau
scandale autour de claude bez
dans un entretien accordé à notre
confrère l'équipe le patron des
girondins reconnaît qu'il a offert des
prostituées à des arbitres de coupe
d'europe et cela à plusieurs reprises
sur les filles de monsieur claude le
commentaire de françois privat
l'aprécial yougoslave do bumba rinne a
longtemps travaillé pour le compte des
girondins de bordeaux
c'était même l'un des hommes de
confiance du président bayle qui
n'hésitait pas à lui donner des
responsabilités
il a traité la plupart des gros
transferts du club et parallèlement il
était chargé d'organiser les réceptions
officielles
à l'occasion des rencontres de coupe
d'europe mais d'après les déclarations
de claude bez à l'équipe ce matin
en 16 ans barine n'a jamais été salarié
des girondins il intervenait plutôt
ponctuellement et s'occuper du choix des
hôtels des voitures des restaurants et
des cadeaux le 2 mars 1988 à l'occasion
du match de coupe d'europe bordeaux psv
eindhoven barine aurait tout de même
fait venir des prostituées de paris afin
de mieux distraire le corps arbitral
avant et après le match
elle serait même resté trois jours
d'après le président des girondins
une révélation qui bien sûr sème le
trouble chez les arbitres et dans le
monde du coup de bol je vais d'une telle
déclaration
et je pense que là si cette déclaration
a été faite sur des ondes
il appartient à la fédération française
de football d'intervenir énergiquement
contre les présidents de clubs qui donne
ce genre d'information c'est extrêmement
grave
non seulement c'est grave pour
l'honorabilité disons des arbitres en
général c'est grave pour la fonction
d'arbitré piché grave jeudi également
pour le garçon à travers non seulement
sa fonction sportive mais également à
travers sa situation professionnelle et
sa vie familiale
maintenant on peut se demander où veut
en venir le président des girondins car
incontestablement cette information sur
de telles pratiques fait un peu désordre
dans l'esprit de l'opinion publique et
porte atteinte à l'image du club est aux
anges de la part d'un homme qui a
toujours mis en avant sa passion pour
les marine et blanc